mr. president by May when your
supporters last night were counting
chanting sent her back why didn't you
stop them why didn't you ask them to
stop saying that well number one I think
I did I started speaking very quickly it
it really was a loud I disagree with it
by the way but it was quite a chance and
I felt a little bit badly about it but I
will say this I did and I started
speaking very quickly but it started out
rather rather fast as you probably
noticed so you'll tell your supporters
never decide I would say that I know
that is I was not happy with it I
disagree with it
but again I didn't say I didn't say that
they did but I disagree but they were
echoing what you said in their first
week they go back well I don't think if
you examine it I don't think you'll find
that but I disagree with anybody else
what I would suggest as I was not happy
with it but what I would suggest you go
there I go to North Carolina and you ask
the people why did they say that but
that's what they said when you'll stop
them if they try to do it again well I
didn't like what they did it and I
started speaking very quickly I could
have a goodness the way I'm sort of
certain well really if you would have
heard it was a tremendous amount of
noise and action and everything else I
started very quickly and I think you
know that I know you may be giving me
too much credit you used to giving me
too much credit
thank you everybody
I would
[Music]
you